digamos que conocemos la circunferencia
de algún círculo ok la circunferencia y
digamos que ésta es igual a 49 pi muy
bien la circunferencia de nuestro
círculo vale 49 pib
con base en ello veamos si podemos
deducir cuál es el radio de esta misma
circunferencia muy bien el radio hasta
ahora no lo como no lo conocemos así que
te invito a que hagas una pausa y trates
de resolver este problema por tu propia
cuenta
así que vamos a tratar de dibujar este
círculo para ayudarnos a resolver o
ayudarnos a visualizar más que nada el
problema verdad entonces digamos que
bueno vamos a imaginar que este fuera un
círculo perfecto de verdad este digamos
un círculo perfecto y vamos a dibujar
también el radio entonces aquí tenemos
el centro de nuestra de nuestro círculo
y aquí tenemos un radio y este radio
mide r digan además nosotros sabemos que
la circunferencia de este círculo se
puede calcular fácilmente como dos veces
pi por r verdad este es el valor de la
circunferencia de hecho para ahondar un
poquito más
nosotros sabemos muy bien que digamos
cuál es la definición de pi verdad y la
definición de pi es la proporción entre
la circunferencia y el diámetro entonces
si nosotros pintamos el diámetro
simplemente sería digamos
extender este radio en la otra dirección
verdad esto también mide r y entonces el
diámetro mide 2 r y de hecho de esta
fórmula lo podemos ver verdad porque
aquí podríamos poner pi que multiplica a
2 r verdad pero 2 r es el valor del
diámetro entonces si pasamos esto verdad
por ejemplo si escribimos la
circunferencia dividida entre el
diámetro esto sería lo mismo que la
circunferencia dividida entre 2 r verdad
ese es el valor del diámetro
entonces si si dividimos la
circunferencia entre 2 r esto nos debe
dar justamente y muy bien pero bueno
hasta este momento nos hemos ido más
lejos de lo que realmente necesitamos
para resolver este problema simplemente
vamos a sustituir los valores en esta
fórmula y veamos qué es lo que obtenemos
entonces nosotros tenemos que nuestra
circunferencia mide 49 pi verdad y esto
será igual a
a dos por r vamos a escribirlo así dos y
por ese entonces para calcular r o
deducir r lo único que necesitamos es
dividir de ambos lados entre dos y muy
bien entonces dividimos de ambos lados
entre dos pi
aquí dos pi se cancela acá del lado
izquierdo los pies se cancelan y
entonces tendremos 49 entre 2 y eso es
24.5 y ese es el valor del radio verdad
este es el valor del radio 24.5 unidades
depende de qué unidades
digamos estemos hablando no podrían ser
metros centímetros o algo por el estilo
hagamos otro ejercicio
ahora vamos a suponer que la
circunferencia es de 1600 pi esto en
algún tipo de unidad puede ser metros y
ahora digamos que queremos encontrar el
valor del diámetro muy bien
entonces nosotros ya habíamos dicho que
la circunferencia es 2 pi por r verdad
es la misma fórmula de aquí y de hecho
esto es pi que multiplica al 2 r verdad
es decir con esta fórmula ahora
podríamos decir que la circunferencia es
igual a ti por diámetro y de hecho
digamos nuevamente esto viene de la
definición tradicional de pi verdad la
la definición de pi es la razón de la
circunferencia entre el diámetro
entonces tenemos la razón de la
eso es el valor de pi verdad y en
realidad los círculos son figuras
fundamentales cuando queremos estudiar
el universo y si tomamos esta proporción
obtenemos esta constante que parece
máquina mágica y que de hecho es
bastante impresionante siempre que
estudiamos matemáticas verdad pero bueno
con esta fórmula ahora podríamos ya
deducir el diámetro verdad porque
entonces la circunferencia es
de 1600 pi y esto debe ser igual a pi
por diámetro entonces dividimos de ambos
lados entre pi verdad del lado derecho
se cancelan y del lado izquierdo también
y obtenemos que el diámetro es 1600 así
que la circunferencia digamos media mil
600 unidades quizás digamos en metros
entonces el diámetro mide 1600 metros
son las unidades que hayas tomado